I'M HERE WITH MY PANEL.
NIGHTLY SHOW WRITER HOLLY
WALKER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> COMEDIAN AND ACTRESS SUSIE
ESSMAN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> AND CO-HOST OF THE VIEW AND
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "MADAM
PRESIDENT," NICOLLE WALLACE.
>> IT'S A NOVEL.
MADAM PRESIDENT.
>> I LIKE THE WAY YOU SAY THAT.
>> IT'S GOOD.
THIS TIME MAGAZINE THING I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT FIRST
I'LL JUST QUOTE IT AGAIN.
DR. JULIE --
[LAUGHING]
>> SO, SHE SAID BIOLOGICALLY
SPEAKING POST MENOPAUSAL WOMAN
ARE IDEAL CANDIDATES FOR
LEADERSHIP.
THEY'RE PRIMED TO HANDLE STRESS
WELL. AND THERE IS OF COURSE NO
MORE STRESSFUL JOB THAN THE
PRESIDENCY. IS THERE TRUTH IN
THAT? I'M NOT SUGGESTING ANYONE
IS POST MENOPAUSAL.
>> I'M PROUDLY POST MENOPAUSAL.
>> GOOD.
>> HERE IS WHAT I THINK ABOUT
THAT.
THE STATEMENT IS NOT IN ITSELF
TRUE.
THE STATEMENT WOULD BE FALSE IF
SHE ADDED PREMENOPAUSAL WOMAN
ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO BE
PRESIDENT. I THINK AS YOU GET
OLDER YOU ARE MORE EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE STRESS BUT
SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO ME
IS LIKE SAYING IF WE HAVE A MALE
PRESIDENT HE HAS TO BE A EUNICH
OR A CASTRATI.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING YOU CAN'T
HAVE A MAN WITH A SEX DRIVE BE
PRESIDENT.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A WOMAN WHO IS
MENSTRUATING BE PRESIDENT.
IT'S STUPID
>> I AGREE.
>> I KNOW YOU HAD A GUEST WITH
THE BOOK "WHEN THE BALLS DROP."
I THINK TIME MAGAZINE OWES AS
MANY COLUMN INCHES TO SAY WHERE
MEN ARE IN THE PROCESS.
THAT'S A THING.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
THEY ACHE, THEY DROP.
>> YOU KNOW THIS ABOUT
BRAD GARRETT'S BALLS?
>> I THINK --
>> IT'S IN THE BOOK.
>> OKAY.
>> NICOLLE IF THEY HAVE PROSTATE
PROBLEMS THEY PEE NONSTOP.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> HOW CAN YOU STARE DOWN
VLADIMIR IF YOU HAVE TO PEE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> SERIOUSLY.
>> VERY GOOD POINT.
>> IF MENOPAUSAL WOMEN ARE ON
THE TABLE SO ARE BALL ACHES.
>> OKAY.
IF A MAN IS 35 OR 40 HE MAYBE
JERKING OFTEN 10 TIMES A DAY.
THAT'S WHAT GUYS DO.
>> MAYBE.
>> THEN WE CAN ONLY HAVE EUNICHS
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> ISN'T CASTRATI LIKE AN
ITALIAN CAR?
I ACTUALLY THINK THERE IS SOME
TRUTH TO IT.
I THINK THAT POST MENOPAUSAL
WOMAN ARE IDEAL CANDIDATES.
I THINK THAT PREMENOPAUSAL WOMEN
ARE GREAT CANDIDATES.
I THINK DURING MENOPAUSAL ARE
GREAT CANDIDATES.
ALL OF THE PAUSALS ARE GOOD
CANDIDATES.
>> ALL THE OF THE PAUSALS.
>> CAN I --
>> GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
>> HERE IS THE THING WHEN I WAS
PREMENOPAUSAL AND HAD A PERIOD
ONCE A MONTH, I RAN A CAREER, I
BROUGHT UP CHILDREN, I RAN A
HOUSEHOLD.
I DID ALL OF THESE THINGS PLUS
BLEEDING EVERY MONTH.
HOW COULD I POSSIBLY DO THAT
HAVING MY PERIOD --
>> NICOLLE, YOU HAVE A FULL-TIME
JOB.
>> YES I WAS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND EVERY 28 DAYS I BLED
BUT THE COUNTRY WENT ON.
>> OH.
>> THERE HAS BEEN ENOUGH WOMEN
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WOMEN AS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISORS.
LISTEN THIS IS -- THIS IS YOUR
TOPIC NOT OURS.
>> TELL IS ABOUT THE BLEEDING
EVERY 28 DAYS.
>> LARRY, I'M BLEEDING RIGHT
NOW.
[BEEP]
>> EVERYTHING IS --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YES YOU'RE SPEAKING.
>> I'M TALKING AND THINGS ARE
OKAY.
>> WE'RE NOT VICTORIAN WOMAN
HAVING FAINTING SPELLS
>> YOU KNOW --
>> OKAY.
>> ON THE FAINTING COUCH,
ARRRGGGH!
ON PERIOD CAN'T TALK.
SOMETHING'S WRONG! MORE
CHOCOLATE AND SALTED NUTS!
[LAUGHING]
>> TO ME -- IT'S LIKE WE'RE
ACTING LIKE WOMEN ARE A CREATURE
WE HAVE NEVER MET BEFORE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WHAT'S THIS BIOLOGY WE'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH?
>> YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
THE AUDIENCE ARE POTENTIALLY
BLEEDING RIGHT NOW?
THINGS ARE NOT GOING -- WE'RE
NOT BURNING DOWN STUFF.
WE CAN STILL TALK.
>> THE WHOLE SUBJECT -- I FIND
IT OFFENSIVE.
I DO.
>> HOW SHOULD HILLARY HANDLE
IT?
>> SHE SHOULDN'T PAY ATTENTION.
>> REAGAN HANDLED ALL THIS STUFF
WITH JOKES.
WHEN THEY TALKED ABOUT HIS AGE.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE HE HAD
ALZHEIMERS
>> NO BUT HE SLAMMED MONDALE.
I THOUGHT HILLARY COULD SAY
"HOPE AND GONE THROUGH THE
CHANGE."
>> THEY LIKE IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OR HOW ABOUT IF HOLLY WAS THE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
I'M BLEEDING RIGHT NOW, WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO?
>> IGNORE IT.
>> DON'T GIVE IT ENERGY.
IT'S A RIDICULOUS TOPIC.
>> THE VOTERS WILL MAKE THEIR
OWN CORRECTIONS.
THEY HAVE A WAY TO SIFT THROUGH
THIS.
THE PEOPLE DETERMINING THE
OUTCOME OF PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS ARE WOMEN.
>> THEY ARE THE LARGEST GROUP OF
SWING VOTERS AND INDEPENDENTS.
THAT'S WHO THE CANDIDATES ARE
SPEAKING TO IN THE END, IN THE
CLOSING DAYS OF ANY ELECTION
SO THEY'RE IMPORTANT.
>> YES, THEY ARE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHEN OTHER
WOMEN THROW SHADE ON WOMEN
SOMETIMES.
I WANT TO SHOW THIS CEO CLIP.
I THINK YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS ON
MORNING JOE.
>> I AM A STRONG WOMEN.
I RUN MY OWN COMPANY LIKE YOU
SAID.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE SAME AS
RUNNING THE BEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD AND BEING COMMANDER IN
CHIEF AND HEAD OF STATE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
TO ME SHOULD BE A MAN.
NOT A FEMALE.
>> OKAY.
OBVIOUSLY --
>> WAS SHE TRANSGENDER.
>> NO.
DON'T GO DOWN THAT ROAD, SUSIE
>> JUST ASKING.
>> OBVIOUSLY SHE'S CRAY.
>> SHE SAYS --
>> ARE WOMEN, WOMENS BIGGEST
OBSTACLES?
>> THEY CAN BE.
SHE SAID IN HER FACEBOOK POST IF
A WOMAN WON SHE WOULD MOVE TO
CANADA.
>> IF A WOMAN WON SHE WOULD MOVE
TO CANADA?
>> YES.
>> PLEASE, HILLARY WE NEED YOU
NOW MORE THAN EVER.
>> THOSE POOR CANADIANS.
>> DEMOCRATS THREATEN TO MOVE TO
CANADA TOO FOR REPUBLICANS
WE HAVE TO HOLD ANYONE THIS
CYCLE --
>> THIS MENSTRUAL CYCLE?
>> YES.
>> IT'S NOT FAIR TO THE
CANADIANS. THEY'RE LOVELY
PEOPLE
>> THEY'VE GOT MORE SPACE
THOUGH.
>> I DON'T THINK THE CANADIANS
WANT ANY OF THESE PEOPLE.